Rene is in Chicago
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Rene hi
thank you well I'm in Lexington Kentucky
going to Chicago Dave my question is how
do I let my mother and family my mother
and father that are 89 and 91 how did
they retire financially secure my dear
sister sold a million to an a million
and a half dollars from them over the
last 20 to 30 years
my brother-in-law scammed my parents my
sister was there to take money every
week my two brothers and I found out
about this about two years ago we knew
my father was giving my sister money but
not totally wife I mean wiping him out
so technically speaking she didn't steal
it they gave it to her basically dad
gave her quite a bit
however she opened 29 charge cards you
know 10 years ago 0% interest maxed each
one out in her name or his name in my
mother's name
and in her in his name without his
knowledge and in my mother's name
without her knowledge
that's identity theft and yes that is
theft and yes you go to jail for that
that's a federal crime how long ago did
she do that she's been doing this for
about 20 years it's a strange I'm sorry
has she done it recently Oh up until two
years ago until we caught her okay so
you've stopped it now we've totally
stopped good now she's going to jail in
jail well I had elder abuse Georgia
elder abuse come out the next day they
called the sheriff the sheriff said
let's put her in jail my dad who does
have a little bit of dementia said no
way
mother who knew nothing about this all
of a sudden said I can't put my daughter
in jail now two years later after my
mother knows what extent that have left
her broke she said let's put her in jail
it's too late yeah my brother-in-law's a
scammer got my dad hooked up into a
scammer gave him bottom line is the
money's gone and nobody was willing to
prosecute while you could so now we just
have to broke old people that gave their
money away yes now they make a good
salary they make about fifty five
thousand a year and then they have
assets that are about sixty five sixty
five thousand dollars worth of assets
no no income coming in sets do they have
okay so what's creating the sixty five
thousand pension
annuities my dad nobody hasn't asked
that one which is in the annuity Oh
I you know it's through the state I
don't know that I don't know anything
now they they oh no it gets better they
had a home equity loan and she went
through three hundred thousand avail I'm
doing with her
okay I'm done with her she's gone they
didn't prosecute her let's move on okay
all I want to talk about is them how
much money do they have now none okay do
they own any real estate yes okay loan
they own a home worth about three
hundred thousand if there is only I have
paid off quite a bit there was a hundred
and twenty three hundred twenty-five
thousand dollar key locks on it home
equity loans I have paid all of them
well we have all together my brothers
and I paid most of them off and there's
about $64,000
okay good and do they have and they have
no cash and they have
they have 65,000 coming in and pensions
and 55,000 from something else so they
have a hundred and ten thousand dollars
a year come No
65,000 total coming in okay correct so
they have a sixty five thousand dollar
income and they have a sixty five
thousand dollar mortgage on a three
hundred thousand dollar house and that's
their total financial picture correct
okay can they live on sixty-five
thousand they can live on sixty-five
thousand okay I mean he may end up in a
nursing home and you all may be funding
some of that or you may have to pay for
some in-home care to come care for him
or you may sell the house and move them
in with one of you all but they can
definitely make it on sixty five
thousand and it's just a horrid shame
that your sisters and her husband are
truck and that no one was willing to put
them in where they belong in jail but
that's just gone that's water under the
bridge now you can't live in that anger
because no one was willing to do
anything about it at the time the people
that were necessary to sign the arrest
warrants were not willing to sign the
arrest warrants and I understand that I
mean it's heartbreaking for your own kid
to be a crook I get that or your own
sister to be a crook I get that but
that's all in the past now we're down to
pretty simply two old people one with
dementia that make fifty $65,000 your
income they have a sixty five thousand
dollar mortgage on three hundred
thousand on our house that's it
and so you've either got to downsize
them in-house and get rid of the
mortgage and then they can afford to
bring in help in that situation to take
care of him or we've got to find
different living arrangements for him if
he's unable to care for himself and
that's the process you go through but
I'm sorry what a horrible horrible thing
that you guys have been through and I
don't blame you for being angry but I
will tell you this I would suggest just
putting it behind you
cuz it's done it's done it's over I mean
I wouldn't be in the same room with her
and I certainly don't want to near
anything near anything that has a number
on it that regarding anybody's finances
and if she comes anywhere near your
parents again for God's sakes put her in
jail
immediately she's got to say she and her
scam artist husband have to stay away
from them because they don't have enough
they don't any more money to get I mean
she's bled them dry like you said and so
and they're obviously scum unbelievable
so it's just man thanks for calling in
you know a large percentage of identity
theft is by someone you know I mean
there's two kinds of identity theft
there's the crooks
you know the people scamming the
internet phishing the internet you know
there in Russia or something or wherever
they are right and they're scamming the
Internet and they're just cleaning out
people's Social Security numbers and
identity issues you know they clean out
you know Equifax and they get the
information they hack Equifax right and
get the information and they use that
that's a classic internet crook and when
we think of identity theft that's what
we like to think of this mysterious
person in a basement somewhere pecking
on a computer but truthfully it's
usually your sister or your parents or
your kids or your cousin truthfully it's
somebody that was your roommate and
that's the two types of identity theft
that are out there and some identity
theft protection things do not cover
familial meaning family identity theft
it's one of the things that we like
about endorsing zandars identity theft
and the reason we all have in DES anders
identity theft on all of us here at
ramsey is because it covers that and you
know then you wouldn't go and pay off
the credit cards and the mother's name
that the sister opened you would simply
turn it over to Xander's I didn't have
people and they would pursue the whole
thing and get that wiped out rather than
wiping out the money same thing with the
he locks if the he locks were illegally
signed without power of attorney you
can't sign someone else's name that's
called identity theft even if it's your
mother even if it's your child even if
it's your wife
you can't sign anyone else's name other
than yours unless you have a power of
attorney
that's called identity theft it's a
federal crime you guys it's stealing and
when you do that to your parents or you
do that to your own kids you're what's
known as scum
unbelievable bottom feeders Wow Renee
I'm so sorry
sorry you guys are facing this I'm mad
with you but let's move on and go help
Mom and Dad this is the Dave Ramsey show